so let's let's talk about socialism and
I use that because it's more of a
buzzword but when I look at you know so
we started by talking about school
choice issues and the real problem here
is well outside of schools its
government monopolies by mandate
basically you've got police departments
for instance you've got just government
institutions as a whole that have
instantly monopolized institution and
you end up with these ineffective
bloated terrible services because they
have no incentive to improve so this
whole school choice thing that we've
been talking about is is interesting me
because it exemplifies the bigger
problem with the instant monopolization
of power when it comes to this socialist
idea that the government should run all
healthcare you're like you realize you
are taking away any incentive and option
for competition improvement because
there will never be a reason other than
people complain but when you have market
incentives and I'm not a laissez faire
guy I'm fairly moderate I think
regulation and different programs can
work but I also think one of the biggest
problems we have in economics would be
general monopolization if corporations
instantly dominate a market like you see
with Google we get censorship we get
manipulation we get abuse of power
that's bad why would we snap our fingers
and vote to monopolize all power in
another area it makes literally no sense
to me
does it make any sense and yeah a lot of
the same people who think that big tech
monopolies are a bad thing big
pharmaceutical monopolies are a bad
thing
and other types of monopolies is that if
they're in the private sector they'll
say that they're a bad thing but then
they turn around and say that the public
school monopoly is a good thing doesn't
make any sense just be consistent I
don't like any of these types of
monopolies I don't like crony capitalism
I don't like the pharmaceutical
companies getting patents that lasts
forever and keeps everybody else out of
the market to where they can you know
raise the price in you know almost
infinitely so I don't like that either
but you know I think people should just
be consistent you you should you
shouldn't like any type of concentration
of power like that you should like for
people to have options in all types of
all sectors of the economy you know what
scares me with situations like this is
that it really does feel like there's
too many people who think it's about my
team winning nothing else because how
can you sign look I think what people
don't realize is that
Google is an organization it is a is a
top-down organization and to an extent
you can call it an authoritarian
organization in that the people the top
control everything without question now
there are regulations based on laws but
for the most part thing and fire who
they want they can hire who they want
they can implement what they want and
they can cut you off from your resources
by the snap snapping their fingers
governments like the US government is to
an extent more and less authoritarian
but it's still another system where you
you want to restrict its power just like
any major corporation what's what's
interesting to me is that people don't
seem to realize government is is is a
group of people who function in a
certain way and do things the same as
any other company and when you
consolidate all power within one group
of people you end up with tyranny
Authority you know people get abused
with the rights abused why would we
choose to do that instantly so when I
when I look at governments when it comes
to like if I had to make a choice
between socialism or laissez-faire
capitalism I'm not I don't think
laissez-faire capitalism leads to is the
right choice for what we should have but
I choose it any day over socialism
complete open free markets as opposed to
complete government consolidation yeah I
completely agree you know a lot you know
a lot of the times I like to say that
the free market is the voluntary sector
whereas the government sector is the
coercive sector right so you know and
I've also said that private monopolies
are preferable to government-run
monopolies because at least you can opt
out of the private monopolies I don't
have to pay for Google services it's
really hard right really hard yeah but
like in order for you know if I want to
not pay for the military bombing people
in other countries I can't just I can't
just move to Texas I'll still have to
pay those federal taxes to pay for these
things I don't agree with you literally
can't move anywhere America I believe is
the only country yeah it's worse it's
worse elsewhere you well know if you're
an American citizen and you go move to a
foreign country like you still owe taxes
it's not it's not as cut and dry as well
people think it is because I have
friends who are like expats but yeah you
still owe America taxes even if you live
in a different country because there are
coming for you so you can't even it's
it's you know so the I I you know one of
the arguments I've been have with a lot
of people we talk about and I say this
too because there's there
nuance to it if you don't like it you
can leave you know if you don't want to
pay taxes go move to different country
well you'd actually have to renounce
your citizenship to yeah so it's not a
very you know it's a very highly costly
your movement so I mean like at least
you know if we're talking state-level
policy at least you can leave from
California to Texas if you don't like
income taxes right state level for
example other people are doing that
but if you're if you if you don't like
the US military doing things and you
know right yeah it's kind of screwed at
that point nothing you can do because
even if you move to like most other of
the like NATO countries like they're
still they're still doing the same thing
they're all part of the same thing
funding the five I spy clubs etc but you
know it's gonna be set up like this at
the state level either I mean like I
shouldn't have to pay for X grocery
store if I'm not consuming those
services right and just like that just
like that issue I shouldn't have to pay
for this school if I'm not consuming
that school's services I understand
there's like positive spillovers
for example there could be like benefits
social benefits but that doesn't that
doesn't lead to can paying for you know
monstrous shopping malls schools for
everyone for rich people and for poor I
and I'm this I'm okay with subsidizing
least advantaged but the system that we
have doesn't do that today we we pay for
schooling for everyone through the
property tax system right regardless of
the type of school that they use so the
incentives are all backwards you know if
your school isn't doing a good job a lot
of the times it gets more money the
government school because they can say
look we're not doing well because we
don't have enough money so the
incentives are completely backwards it's
paradoxical and it's like you have these
people who complain about say the police
they need police accountability it's
like well because you've a monopoly dude
there's no there's no incentive for them
to actually do better because for one
their union is gonna make sure that if
anyone does anything wrong they're gonna
protect him and then there's one in your
area so guess what you're paying for it
yeah if you don't like police monopolies
you should also be worried about
government-run school monopolies as well
it's the same kind of issue that when
you concentrate power and you only have
one provider of the service they tend to
get really expensive over time and they
tend to not do a very good job because
you can't vote with your feet elsewhere
unless you move somewhere else which is
very painful very hard to do just
imagine if you had to move houses every
time you wanted to change this is your
story
there's a lot buried in this
conversation too and in like for
instance in California and during the
drought they voted away the surface
water rights of certain farming
communities they basically said the
surface water should be diverted to the
cities because the people need it it's
basically like this if you have a
hundred people in one area and ten and
the other the hundred people vote to
take your resources away and so this is
it's another it's another problem
because I do want to kind trying to
focus on the problem of having a
monopoly over control of your resources
over control of your institutions and so
you end up with me and you can kind of
think of a school choice kind of
mechanism for policing as well I've
actually written on this I wrote a paper
called police choice it's published in
the journal or it's the libertarian
papers journal and it applies the same
arguments to school choice and says this
is this is probably why we have a bad
you know and in some circumstances a lot
of abuse of power with police and then
also discrimination by race could be an
issue by police as well and it's
partially because you know if someone's
abusing someone else if a police officer
is abusing your rights you can't vote
with your feet and you know incentivize
them whole time not because it's a
monopoly same thing with the schools the
socials don't do a good job because look
if you don't want to use it you still
have to pay for it
but also you're not the customer you're
not because it's product right right
we'll see
so you're providing the resources to the
customer and the customer is buying from
the distributor essentially so basically
with a voucher system in any capacity
even if it was about like say police
which is an interesting thing you
brought up then you could go to a police
department and they're gonna try and do
right by you because you literally pay
them imagine if they started pissing off
the community and all of a sudden they
started losing paying subscribers
exactly they'd have reforms that
apologized they'd fire people they bet
we're gonna fix it we're gonna fix it
and their pros and cons there but right
now what's happening is you have town
hall you know the city government or
whatever that's the customer for the
police so the police say we don't want
these people you know let's say people
are protesting
yeah well go in the rest of money
we don't care why you do it there's
businesses and the business are giving
us tax money we don't care about the
individuals imagine if there was the
individuals along with businesses who
provided the vouchers well then the
police department's gonna be alike we're
gonna lose like a thousand voucher
holders for our department if we don't
violate their rights so and you can
imagine choosing you know and this can
all be government still I'm not you know
I'm not gonna go full fledge and say
this this will be all private providers
of policing it could be it could work
that way but you know just just for the
average listener just let's just assume
it's all government-run police
departments and you can pick you know
online just based on you know what's
your response time what's your average
response time or if you just see in the
media that this police department you
know killed an innocent person I don't
want to send my tax dollars that way
anymore so I can send it elsewhere and
so it could all it could be funded the
same way it's funded now and just give
individuals their funding back from the
tax system and let them allocate where
those dollars go its ought to follow the
same laws right right and they would be
over so they'll be looking over seeing
body or internal affairs or you know
what I mean
you'd have you'd have a constitutional
protection not like you know law
enforcement and the federal government
likes to adhere to the Constitution for
the most part excitin qualified immunity
right like won't explain that what you
mean well they really they can pretty
much just say that you know they're they
were doing the best they could you know
they're just
and so they it's essentially it gives
them unlimited rights to to abuse power
if and and think about the reaction in
places like Ferguson when they feel like
they have no power to fight back against
the police force imagine what would
happen if the police did something and
whether they were right or wrong all of
a sudden the community said we're not
funding it anymore now the policeman was
gone
there you go no more I mean this would
be this would be a move in you know that
would that would actually benefit police
officers too because then you know for
doing a good job they'd actually be
rewarded for responding quickly and and
for now using nonviolent desperation
techniques so bigger budgets bigger
salaries more you know bigger facilities
better facilities better equipment yeah
they'd have you know an incentive not to
waste the money then they'd have an
incentive to not disrespect people's
rights okay I guess I do see a challenge
in that in imagine if there's you know
there's gonna be a finite of
finite amount of money to go to what
beat a school or or a police department
right mm-hmm if that's true what if the
police just literally don't have the
resources to give good response times
would you you'd still end up with a bad
department you'd say I want to pull you
know my voucher from this one but then
you end up with two crappy departments
because the vouchers are split you know
what I mean
yeah but then now that if there were
economies of scale is essentially the
argument that I think you're making if
there's economies of scale then it would
just collapse into essentially having
the same thing we have today which is a
sum right the geographic again so if
that's the case no it's no worse than
what we already have but at least in
theory you know if they can cut cost if
there is a way to spend money more
efficiently than that would lead to
faster response times it just all
depends and I won't be I'm not like a
gypsy with a crystal ball saying how
would actually work but I would think
that you know they're not maximizing
efficiency right now just based on what
what we see every day with the police
departments I mean again this is an
anti-police at all you know we can we
can support people who are protecting us
but at the same time seeing that there
are some bad bad actors out there and
also you know in this system we would
vote with our feet with that voucher to
the police departments who are doing a
kick-ass a very good job yeah so I mean
I think that would be a win-win for the
customers but also the providers of the
service as well as this is the same
argument that I make about school choice
right it's a monopoly issue exactly so
that that was those the gist of what I
wanted to get like you know we can talk
about schools you know like we did but I
wanted to you know kind of kind of
address us more from a problem of
imagine if the only restaurant you only
had one restaurant it they have no
reason to be better than anyone else
they can give you crappy food because
they're like we're gonna go actually you
know what South Park you see the South
Park episode where they go to the cable
company and so they're complaining the
cable company and the guy rips the the
his shirt so exposes nipples and touch
robbing I'm going oh no what are you
gonna do we're gonna do about it yeah
they have a monopoly
yeah and that's and that's a private
monopoly but that's you know what man I
don't know how we got to this point
there's a lot of speculation but how do
we get to a point where you literally
have you it was the left that was
supposed to be opposing monopolization
of power at least the left for me
growing up that the not this far left
socialist
like they were capitalist but they're
like hey big corporations are bad too
now they're arguing Google should Google
as a private company they can do it they
want and now they're also saying like
yes but socializing medicine and
abolishing private healthcare is a good
idea - it seems like inconsistent
doesn't it well I mean it seems like
they changed and now they're claiming to
be like they're just literally
monopolists like they're arguing for
monopoly I don't understand it it's it's
it's like you want some overlord to tell
you what to do yeah problem I usually
just focus on the education tidbits but
like if you look at the first draft of a
OCS you know green new deal she called
for you know to dismantle monopolies was
one of the issues and I was like oh well
ALC is coming out to support universal
school choice because we have public
school monopolies all across the United
on of course she didn't mean that it was
only private monopolies thanks for
checking out this segment from the Tim
cast IRL podcast we do the show every
Monday through Friday at 8 p.m.
sometimes an hour or two and we do have
a full live recorded version of the show
that includes a lot of comments and
smaller segments you probably don't see
if you want to check that out you can
watch live at 8 p.m. Monday through
Friday or become a member of this
channel and for five bucks a month you
get full access to all of the recorded
podcasts every day after the show we
make them available in the community
section of this YouTube channel so don't
forget to subscribe and stick around for
more segments and more shows Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next show
you